[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre 7,8
loisirs ravi de vous retrouver pour 13
minutes d'idées de sorties le sommaire
de ce jeudi 21 février pendant les
vacances scolaires associations et
municipalité se mobilisent pour occuper
vos enfants à plaisir nous nous sommes
initié à la création de dessins animés
sur tablettes tactiles ateliers et
balades familiales le petit moulin des
vaux de cernay propose un programme
riche
laura les cas sera avec nous pour un
avant goût nous les avons rencontrés
alors qu'elles avaient encore les mains
dans le cambouis les deux copines
plaisir oise du coin équipage 1104 sont
à biarritz au départ du 4l trophy à bord
de leur bolide rose nous suivrons ce
départ d' aventure les vacances
scolaires commencent de nombreux stages
des ateliers sont proposés à vos enfants
dans les yvelines
nous les avons nous avons suivi un
atelier pour apprendre à créer son
dessin animé sur tablette à plaisir il
adore sauter des dessins ils allaient
les pinceaux elle pot de peinture mme
des outils virtuels pour créer son
propre personnage de dessin animé ce
matin ces jeunes plaisir waeles leur
créativité s'exprimer sur tablettes
tactiles avec les pots de peinture c'est
très intéressant parce qu'on peut fermer
trois grands fils est tout à fait
d'accord
j'ai fait une rome italie et mort
l'amour
je vais me fâcher
des gens mais voilà ils vont dessiner
les personnages et ses décors et à
laisser les films est normalement un
plus sur ces incidents qui ont dit on va
faire bref un peu touché à tout pour
voir si on peut on va pouvoir arriver à
faire les toits cet apport de films et
d'animations pour cette initiation
express l'animatrice de l'atelier leur a
donné trois mois pour les aider à
construire leurs histoires comptines
danser là on avait même au format requis
10 mois dopés par exemple est un jour
rien je t'apporte est apparue sur scène
après les surprises jeux ludiques pour
aussi éveiller les enfants à la
diversité sur des thématiques avec this
way qui me touchent moins c est qu il y
avait enfin se mettre et une conscience
en pourvoirie nos traditions créer son
dessin animé s'avère facile sur un outil
qu'évidemment il maîtrise parfaitement
ça c'est pour les couleurs et pour
défiler jusqu'à mettre le doigt sur
l'écran une fois les dessins terminer
l'histoire imaginée le logiciel aligne
tous les personnages prennent vie de la
tablette tactile au petit théâtre en
bois pour continuer d'entrer dans son
monde imaginaire le centre socioculturel
le scarabée à la verrière s'associent
pour un atelier de création kamishibaï
une technique de comptes d'origine
japonaise aux principes simples des
images défilent dans un bouteille en
petit théâtre en bois
l'atelier est gratuit sur inscription
pour les plus grands de 11 à 15 ans il
sort les bombes de peinture la ville de
guyancourt propose un stage street art
objectif s'exprimer sur l'égalité femmes
hommes en plein mois du temps des femmes
de la ville vous pouvez vous inscrire
auprès du point jeunes de la république
ou du service jeunesse de l'hôtel de
ville jusqu'au samedi 23 février pour
des sorties en famille au coeur du parc
de la vallée de chevreuse le musée du
petit moulin propose des animations
spéciales avec nous en plateau lorrain
les cas vous êtes responsable du musée
bonjour bonjour alors le petit moulin
ouvert à la fin de l'été 2016 elle
enregistre environ 6000 visiteurs par an
et vous y proposer des visites guidées
dont la prochaine est ce dimanche 24
février
oui tout à fait c'est sur des visites
guidées que nous proposons en moins deux
fois par mois qu'ils sont
assurée par nos soins en interne et donc
qui durera environ une heure et quart et
propose donc découvrir ce musée lors
d'une visite guidée très complète et on
y découvre quoi dans ce musée justement
on y découvre le paysage extraordinaire
des votes cerner à travers de trois
thématiques la formation géologique de
ce site
l'évolution historique également et
notamment le patrimoine hydraulique
quand on peut y découvrir puisqu'il ya
une histoire des chaînes solidaire de
six moulins à eau qui date du moyen-âge
et puis la réprésentation du paysage au
19e siècle par une colonie des peintres
paysagistes qui sont venus très nombreux
à avoir posé leur chevalet dans ces
paysages et donc ses peintres on peut
peut-être même les retrouver parce que
pendant les vacances proposé un atelier
de carte postale
tout à fait l'atelier créatif le drôle
de 4 postale propose une création des
cartes postales à partir des paysages et
les métiers à 1,6 et du passé c'est une
façon ludique et à la fois instructif de
découvrir les paysages d'autrefois dans
la vallée de votre cerner
donc mais aussi de l'airé de se
réapproprier en justement créer leurs
propres cartes postales d'une façon à
aller s'est exprimé à leur imagination à
l' esprit créatif et donc des corps et
des cartes postales et créer leur propre
carte postale c'est pour qui cet atelier
donc cet atelier s'adresse aux enfants
de 6 à 12 ans est donc bien évidemment
c'est sur inscription sur inscription
sur le site internet qui va s'afficher
aussi une visite familiale
oui tout à fait donc la semaine d'après
le 7 mars à 15 heures nous proposons une
visite guidée familiale pour découvrir
justement la vie dans les votes cerner
au 19e siècle en parlera des métiers
anciens comme le meunier les lavandières
les agriculteurs ou encore
la pisciculture et mais également des
peintres paysagistes de leur façon de
travailler et donc découvrir les
paysages à travers d'une malle
pédagogique pour découvrir les outils
dont se servaient donc les peintres pour
peindre directement sur le motif donc
c'est vraiment une visite en famille où
on apprend peu d'effet donc c'est une
une visite qui s'adressent à un public
familial donc les familles sont les
bienvenues avec les enfants c'est
justement une visite plus approprié au
public des hommes des enfants mais aussi
à dresde est plus adulte
donc avant de se quitter vous vouliez
lancé un appel à candidatures pour le
projet qui vous tient à coeur c'est une
journée spéciale qui aura lieu le 23
jours oui tout à fait donc le parc
naturel a lancé un appel à candidatures
pour l'animation du site du petit moulin
de vaux de cernay lors du pique nique
des peintres paysagistes donc
précisément dans color du dimanche 23
juin ce sera donc la troisième édition
déjà
si tu as deux autres qui ont lieu ont eu
lieu et et dont l'objectif est de faire
revivre l'époque de deuxième deuxième
moitié du 19e siècle dans la vallée des
vaux de cernay où les excursionnistes
venu un par le chemin de fer parisseaux
ont pris possession de ces paysages
également les peintres et très nombreux
à voir peuvent poser leur chevalet dans
la vallée et donc du coup nous
souhaitons faire appel à des acteurs
locaux donc
nous invitons à s'associer à cette
journée donc les associations
culturelles et historiques encore des
artistes qui souhaiterait donc
vers venir et participer à cette journée
pour évoquer les peintres paysagistes à
l'époque
et donc si vous souhaitez participer à
cette journée vous avez le site internet
pour rentrer en contact avec le petit
moulin
merci laura les cadettes venu sur notre
planète merci à vous pour votre robinet
vous dans les salles saint-quentinoise
patrie jacques de dixmude s'est rendu au
ciné c'est d'elancourt
le festival signé du nord s'est
poursuivie jusque début mars
[Musique]
cette semaine aussi 17 une programmation
la plus éclectique possible en tout cas
on essaye donc plein de films à
l'affiché
vacances scolaires obligent je vous
donne les titres rapidement alita all
inclusive une intime conviction
excellent à voir avec olivier gourmet
dans la peau de eric dupond moretti
l'ordre des médecins la dernière folie
de claire darling catherine deneuve
bohemian rhapsody qu'on a repris je le
succès qui ne se dément pas de ce film
rage 2.0 pour les enfants minuscule deux
là et la chasse à l'ours et je voulais
surtout insisté sur le festival ciné
junior qui a lieu dans nos salles
pendant toute la durée du mois de
février même jusqu'à début mars donc
deux événements à vous proposer cette
semaine pour les enfants
ainsi défilent ou avec un court métrage
un film de courts métrages capelle drôle
de planète dimanche matin à 10h30 et
surtout venez participer mardi prochain
à 16h 30 à l'atelier incrustation
incrustation pardon on vous expliquera
comment on fait des administrations dans
les films à partir de fonds vers vous
avez déjà dû voir ça dans des
documentaires et c'est donc un
spécialiste de l'incrustation viendra
vous parler de cette technique d'effets
spéciaux au cinéma dans nos salles donc
mardi prochain
16h30 aussi 17 dans le cas du festival
si les juniors
[Musique]
les deux plaisirs oise et leur 4l rose
ont quitté saint quentin en yvelines
direction le maroc
elles sont arrivées mercredi à biarritz
pour le départ de la 22e édition du 4l
trophy 12 jours pour traverser trois
pays jusqu'à marrakech
vous pouvez suivre le parcours de
marianne et justin sur leur compte
instagram en park inn sable ainsi que
sur le site officiel de la course
nous les avions rencontrés durant leur
préparation c'est une expérience je
pense que l'on voit en apprendre
beaucoup de cette aventure notamment au
nouveau lieu au niveau humain si par
exemple il ya des gens qui sont en
galère on se voit un peu s'arrêter et
demander qu'est ce qui se passe pour
aider quoi c'est une belle façon de
découvrir le maroc et je pense à
attendre une aventure inoubliable
j'espère qu'on n'aura pas trop galère
sur la route le club voisin tennis de
table organise son 10e tournoi national
b 38 apps disponibles au gymnase des
pyramides pour tous les censier
fédération française de tennis de table
qui souhaiteraient enchaîner les matches
le tournoi aura lieu tout le week-end à
voisins le bretonneux
côté foot maurepas 8e du classement
reçoit monter son 10e pour le
championnat de d1 de district les deux
équipes n'ont que quatre petits points
d'écart et se bat pour conserver leur
place en d1
là on peine se disputera au stade du
bout des klaus et dimanche à 15h pour
votre briques sortir en ile de france
nous nous évaluons jusque sur une île
britannique
[Musique]
durant son exil de 1855 à 1870 victor
hugo a entièrement aménagé une maison à
guernesey hauteville house est
aujourd'hui en restauration pour
l'occasion la maison victor hugo hugo
place des vosges à paris lui rend
hommage avec une exposition un reportage
de nos confrères viagra par et la maison
victor hugo de paris expose hauteville
house la maison de victor hugo à
guernesey terre d'exil pour le romancier
il y livre à 15 ans entre 1954 et 1969
un lieu qu'il a façonné au fil des
années à son image celle d'un artiste
ayant fait l'objet d'importantes
rénovations pour préserver l'héritage du
célèbre écrivain hauteville house est la
star de l'exposition
à moins que ce ne soit victor hugo les
deux parce que cette maison est
tellement à son image on a coutume de
dire que c'est un autoportrait de victor
hugo quelque part et c'est vrai qu elle
est chargée d'une symbolique et c'est
une expérience que font les les
visiteurs quand il rentre dans la maison
ils sont saisis parce que victor hugo ne
laisse pas un centimètre carré de vide
double chaque pièce d'une double peau
qui est la projection de son imagination
de sa pensée de sa poésie de sap evry
donc on rentrerait on a montré son
entrée dans le cerveau de victor rico
contre-visite cette maison pour plonger
le visiteur pleinement dans l'univers de
victor hugo un étage entier est consacré
à hauteville house quatre salles dans
lesquelles l'exposition a su mettre en
valeur des pièces directement rapportés
de guernesey
mais aussi beaucoup d'autres archives
beaucoup beaucoup de photographies
anciennes parce que c'est c'est le
principal témoignage que nous pouvons
montrer ici à paris quelques objets qui
ont été liés à l'histoire de cette
maison là derrière moi un coffre qui qui
a été donnée par la famille hugo à la
création du musée
il ya un portrait la jeune adel qui fait
partie de cette pour quatre familles qui
ont été transférés de paris à hauteville
au moment de l'achat de la maison et
qu'on appelle la table aux encrier qui
en fait est un coffre réunissant les les
encriers plus mais un petit mot
manuscrit de victor hugo bien sûr mais
aussi de lamartine d'alexandre dumas et
de george sand hauteville house à la
découverte de victor hugo est à admirer
jusqu'au 14 avril prochain et c'est la
fin de votre cette ut loisirs merci de
nous avoir suivis bon début de vacances
pour les plus chanceux et rendez vous la
semaine prochaine pour de nouvelles
idées sorties
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh